♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
The 64th annual Grammy Awards
were held last night,
and featured a pre-recorded
video from Ukrainian president
Volodomyr Zelenskyy, and I got
to say, as a 48-year-old man,
I was just happy to see someone
at the Grammys
whose name I knew.
[ Laughs ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
on Saturday
visited the White House,
and that is the closest
any New York mayor has gotten
to the White House.
President Biden is set to host
former president Obama tomorrow
at the White House, and you know
Joe is excited.
I'll bet he's turning the house
upside down right now,
looking for
the other controller.
The House on Friday passed
a bill to legalize marijuana,
largely along party lines,
then Don Jr. got excited
because he thought
they had legalized
party lines.
The White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki
is reportedly planning to leave
the Biden administration
in the next several weeks
to host a show
on NBC's streaming platform,
Peacock.
Oh, God. Can I please be there
when you teach Joe
how to download Peacock?
"I need a Roku? Isn't that one
of those Japanese poems?
The media company BuzzFeed,
over the weekend,
shut down its news app.
There were many reasons
for the move,
and number 7 will shock you.
The Navy announced on Friday
it will name a ship
after the late Supreme Court
justice, Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
and this is cool --
Señor Frogs is naming
their 64-ounce margarita
"The Kavanaugh."
President Biden said last week
he believes
Russian President Vladimir Putin
has placed some of top advisors
under house arrest.
Said Putin's oligarch advisors,
"Oh, no, not house arrest."
And finally, Apple is reportedly
said to announce a new policy
to deter thieves from trying
to steal --
excuse me, trying to sell
stolen iPhones --
they're going to slap an Android
sticker on it.
♪♪
Former president Barack Obama
today visited the White House,
and out of habit, Jeanine Pirro
called for his impeachment.
[ Laughter ]
During a Zoom call last summer
with a group
of presidential historians,
former president Trump
reportedly imitated the accent
of the president of South Korea.
Alright, I'm not surprised
he did something
horribly offensive.
I am a little surprised
he did it
on a call with
presidential historians.
[ As Trump ] So, you guys
will be evaluating me
for posterity, right?
Okay.
Then you're gonna love this.
Two lesbians walk into a bar.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
President Biden said yesterday
that Russian president
Vladimir Putin
should face a war crimes trial
for his recent actions
in Ukraine.
Good luck to whoever pulls that
in jury duty.
[ Laughter ]
"Is there any reason
why you shouldn't be selected
for this case?"
"Um, I got a wife and kids."
[ Laughter ]
The Senate Judiciary
Committee's vote
to move Ketanji Brown Jackson's
nomination out of committee
was delayed yesterday because
California senator Alex Padilla
was forced to switch
to a later flight.
Look, I don't care if the fate
of the Supreme Court
hangs in the balance.
They offer you $400 in
flight credits, you take it.
[ Laughter ]
Probably a food voucher.
An environmental group
said in a new report
that it cleaned up nearly
half a million pieces of trash
last year
from New Jersey beaches,
including a fake eyeball.
Wow.
I am shocked.
That it was fake.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I feel like most days
you go to the Jersey Shore,
you're seeing a real eyeball.
[ Laughter ]
The environmental group
also reported
finding male enhancement pills
and a glow-in-the-dark condom,
or as it's known in New Jersey,
solid Tuesday night.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
regular Fox News viewers
who were paid to watch CNN
for 30 days
became more skeptical and less
likely to believe fake news.
Said one participant,
"Before this,
I didn't even know some women
had brown hair."
[ Laughter ]
Crazy.
According to the latest numbers,
the average price for a slice
of pizza in New York City
is now more expensive
than riding the subway.
And for both things,
it's a good idea
to soak up the grease
with a napkin first.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
I mean, I don't --
I don't quite know what we're --
what we want from the audience
when we tell a joke like that.
[ Laughter ]
That was a very fair and
accurate response by all of you.
Every now and then, we like
to set the levels, you know.
We don't say a joke so much
as just a truly disgusting idea.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
16% of Americans
live in the same city or town
that they grew up in.
The other 84% have them muted
on Facebook.
[ Laughter ]
In anticipation
of legal marijuana
being available later this year,
New York governor Kathy Hochul
yesterday
unveiled the state's
Cannabis Conversations campaign,
which I'm guessing is that thing
where the edible kicks in
and you end up
debating your cat.
[ Laughter ]
"I think you're hard
to be around."
[ Laughter ]
"Okay."
The "New York Post"
recently reported
that at least 139 people
around the country
have said they became sick
after eating the breakfast
cereal Lucky Charms,
or as they're now known,
just Charms.
[ Laughter ]
A restaurant in Florida
reportedly canceled
a dinner reservation recently
after discovering the gathering
was a going-away party
for a Capitol rioter
who was sentenced to prison.
Alright, but don't be shocked
if they show up anyway.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities
in Florida announced yesterday
that they arrested six men
who allegedly stole thousands
of dollars' worth of gasoline
from several gas stations.
They would have gotten away, but
thousands of dollars of gasoline
was still only
like a quarter tank.
♪♪
During an event yesterday,
celebrating
the Affordable Care Act,
President Biden welcomed
former president Barack Obama
back to the White House
and said,
"Feels like the good ol' days."
Yeah, I'll be it does.
The good ol' days when you were
just going out for ice cream
and riding shotgun on the
Hope and Change Express.
Sucks when the responsibility
is all yours, doesn't it?
Turns out,
there's a world of difference
between taking an Uber
and driving an Uber.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
is set to sign a bill today
that will increase the financial
stability and reliability
of the US Postal Service.
The bill is called the
Pottery Barn Act of 2022.
Ivanka Trump reportedly
met yesterday
with the House committee
investigating the January
attack on the Capitol
for nearly 8 hours.
Oh, my God, you guys.
She did it!
She worked an 8-hour day!
[ Laughter ]
I knew she could!
I knew she could.
A man on a Southwest Airlines
flight was arrested
over the weekend
after he was allegedly
caught masturbating on board.
He was caught after passengers
heard clapping
before the plane landed.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the second season of
the Netflix series "Bridgerton"
was watched for more than
250 million hours
over the last week,
which is a record
for the most-viewed
English language show,
even though most people
watched it on mute.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was
National Walking Day.
This news first reported
by a sign in the subway.
♪♪
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
today became the first
Black woman to be confirmed
to the Supreme Court,
in case you're wondering
why the flag over the Fox News
building is at half staff.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
today became the first
Black woman to be confirmed
to the Supreme Court.
And I can't believe
I have to say this --
Brett, that champagne
was for everyone.
[ Laughter ]
In a speech
at a union conference,
President Biden joked that
he had forgotten the name
of former President Trump
and said,
"That last guy, what was
his name, anyway?
He never showed up
in the inauguration.
Though, to be fair, it's not
like we showed up to his."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump yesterday
officially endorsed
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
for re-election and said she is
"a warrior who doesn't back down
and doesn't give up."
Basically, all the same reasons
she's banned from Target.
[ Laughter ]
NBC News staffers
are reportedly worried
that the company's decision
to hire
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki
to host a show on MSNBC could
taint the network's credibility.
Meanwhile, Fox News
is almost entirely taints.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy
is the world's most popular
leader among Americans.
But, remember, Volodymyr,
two weeks ago,
Will Smith was our most popular
movie star.
[ Laughter ]
Pinterest announced yesterday
that it will prohibit users
from sharing climate
misinformation on the platform,
forcing them to move to Etsy.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
NASA announced this week
that an asteroid the size
of a small house flew by Earth.
And this is crazy --
it got three offers on Zillow.
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
♪♪